[Music]
in underaged problems news jailbait
submitted by because I'm Batman high
school dropout becomes the highest-paid
pro gamer but still needs his mom to
sign his contract I [ __ ] love gaming
now man oh so much money what does he
play [ __ ] that guy what does he play
what does he play what do we need to
know overwatch he's on overwatch is it
Korean just read though I don't know wo
n W that's a Korean name huh and then
maybe Korean one day wo n o is a created
kaiseki
yes is it wo n one it was J one that
sounds hello korean J that's hella cream
tellin he's 17 years old life you know
what it is no I'll put it like this I
know when people see this or life
doesn't play but he is like the upper
echelon of life game plan so like his
skill level has to do it in overwatch
he's probably mastered all the
characters and you have to know every
like technic
oh how do you explain overwatch yeah
it's a shooter game with different
characters cartoony it's kind of like
the Street Fighter of that there's all
that's the game start by Isaac okay yeah
I know what you're talking about
that looks fine holy well it's not when
you play online with people they talk
talk I don't
yeah it's toxic there's toxic down there
but like what games like this because I
know someone who commentate Street
Fighter and like plays professionally
and stuff like you it's not only just
knowing each character it's how long it
takes to do this how far this thing
reaches to that weapon that's not like
it's so just study the map it's insane
so for him to be at the top in the world
that's amazing insane you guys ona we're
gonna buy Isaac the game no we gotta buy
eyes you can't he can't he can't play
anything online when you play PvE
right he's gonna have carpal tunnel cuz
you know gamers they do a lot of this
and he do a lot of this yeah do you guys
wanna guess how much his contract the
minimum annual salary that that pro
players receive is 50,000 was pretty
good video games not probable the recent
street fighter competition was
seventy-five thousand for the top winner
online no it was in Vegas it was a whole
like a real machine yeah a real thing
yeah I'm glad you paid to do something I
would do for free and waste my life with
exactly that's awesome that's [ __ ]
move that's like welfare dude that since
it's awesome friends get yelled at for
playing video games now these [ __ ]
are making this [ __ ] they're making pay
a hundred no I would say more like
closer to the million maybe five mil I
would say I'm gonna reach for the stars
well no it depends on his sponsorship
and if he wins annual income high
hundreds so he signed a one hundred
fifty thousand per year contract with
NRG Energy yeah how come you got it
right because everyone else is guessing
you should've just stopped it at me
that's [ __ ] amazing
no they all wanted a chance not [ __ ]
that [ __ ] come on if you want to
acknowledge me forgetting number and I
didn't acknowledge a because I'm like
this balls probably would I didn't read
it
don't you with Amazon gaming is that
energy Amazon I don't know it just says
N
ge sports and he also joined NR Gees
overwatch league roster how many years
is his sponsorship young he's he's got a
future he's cool he's cool
y'all set at the age of 17 making a
hundred and fifty K yeah there's like a
million dollars to play video games
other gamers get cuz overwatch is a
hot-shit competition like it's a new
there it's gone eSports it's a new thing
in eSports now like fairly new like
they're barely saying about my friends
commentating for it now it's fairly new
and it's one of the hottest games right
now yeah what's it look like I need to
know what he looks like
you got the 110 pounds I'm dying I just
need to know he's also entitled to 50%
of team bonuses per overwatch League
rules also it's it's at least 150,000 a
year this is Jay yeah he looks like
KevJumba Kevin whoo Wow he's chillin huh
I'm proud of him I would be so proud
[ __ ] yeah I mean I don't relationships
how is he gonna meet a girl in the
future [ __ ] my relationship he said you
could meet another Gina yeah so you
gonna what are you give him a chance or
what I would go to jail cuz he's 17 but
in a year 100,000 is not that much it is
when you're 17 I'm talking about he's
trying to entice her with $150,000 it's
not gonna work she's my [ __ ]
billionaire dude what you did alright
story time tell us about he was an oil
digging tycoon so former male model and
he was a founder of an oil digging tech
all digging company out and that's wrong
how the [ __ ] how the [ __ ] can you get
two wins it's nothing right it's the
ugly rich so you used to be a [ __ ]
professional model that's already a win
but then you [ __ ] succeeded in
business
being an oil [ __ ] yeah magistrate found
him down
did you believe it [ __ ] dude you you
could have had you had it made and then
we're all angry at her because we're
friends with her and we could have had
you guys could be like heaven like a
whole complex like a whole building
right kicking it with you and yes here
you went on a date with him yeah boring
that's why I stopped what do you do you
can't sustain me by you oh we went to
some Steakhouse I was really good more
tunes you know master-master especially
yeah yeah yeah what else happened it's a
billionaire we went to Red Lobster
backstage Oh Mary took you to rent okay
I was gonna say keep going keep going
maestra it was boring I can do it that's
your story so you went to the steak
house and that's I think mommy would
have confused me and I would have tried
harder you shook his hand huh I had a
good time I was like alright well cuz we
were having dinner at the downstairs
restaurant workers hotel was the second
date I was like very well I gotta get
going second date a second date but I am
a second airplane going to take us to
Paris you don't want to go he's handsome
right what do you look like the thing
about him is that his his sense of humor
so dry like when he says something
sarcastically I couldn't tell and then
he has to go that was a joke I was like
oh but see he's hella funny cuz he's
rich where's your boat
every time I go haha
[Laughter]
billionaire a colleague a car is like a
box of tissues you've got like a Honda
or so yeah what has your self-respect
gotten you all right
[ __ ] that [ __ ] up man can you deal with
him you're blowing your false
advertisement you know that like I know
you hang out with these harems you chill
with the harems and they hook you up
with dates with these guys that expect
you to be just like the other bunch of
Jezebel's and when you show up and you
don't do these things they're like what
is this what what is this I I was going
to did he want you more I say that like
he hit me up whenever he was back in
town but then after a while Mike
whatever you're nothing like Stephanie
she's that'd be awful no because we
heard dubai drilled out their oil is oil
mines you visit up when you went to
Dubai no this is when I was like 21
years ago leave this [ __ ] that's 21 I
said there's my self-respect that's
ridiculous you got some respect when you
get older I had it man you wouldn't have
to do any of this stuff
to me like a loser I came here that I'm
never existed girl come on oh I know
actually the younger you are the more
self-respect you have you go
I rather sleep at Motel 6 stoop down to
that level what do you do it now if you
hit you up now that I'm like you know
what now that I'm more mature then I can
actually probably someone yes
I bet you she wasn't even born he was
just a normal guy you were immature he
didn't have a face tattoo on a honda
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
music he'd have a koi fish on his arm
he's one teardrop
so that's you're into that I wasn't to
like full on his shoes my bad he didn't
want to read but it was like but him I
was like I wasn't used to like a Versace
suits and blonde curly blonde hair got
thats don't know I know maybe like that
now oh god you're so song I mean I wish
I was a better gold digger back then
[ __ ] those [ __ ] I knew were good they
smell nobody approaches everybody I
don't know because you know I have a
little bit of money never been
approached I don't know why you have a
girlfriend that's cuz you're humble
about it
nudists the og spelled dial tone dial
yellow bar that's the one that dries out
your skin cool oh you name another one
and listen give an old black band I wish
this carpet in this office needs to be
ivory it's the friction on this carpet I
don't know why but my feet get attracted
to the dirt more than you offer kid hey
you guys want to stock any of us we'll
go ahead down to the description box
below and you can follow us on Instagram
and all kinds of stuff for more videos
[Music]